uh as you know i am kind of a fan of
shazam
kind of uh it was kind of good i'm just
gonna i want to lower the ego yeah sure
of course
of course um but seriously though for
fans that love the first one like me
what can you tease about the sequel
i mean
yeah so i mean i i you know how i feel
about spoilers so i or how we all should
feel about spoilers which is we don't
say them um
but i will say that
i i genuinely and this is not just lip
service i i really do think that we
you know i'm very proud of the first one
i think we made a really really good
movie uh i think the second one is
better i think that we
uh we had more time we had more budget
uh everyone
you know we had essentially the entire
cast returning um
and uh
we all knew our characters a little bit
more we could we could you know kind of
sit into them a little bit more
um
uh um henry gayden who wrote the first
script wrote the second and he did a
fantastic job doing so um
yeah i don't know man like everything
just clicked even a little bit more and
a little bit more and and also the kids
have grown up a little bit more so even
the sensibilities of them becomes even
slightly bit
more mature which brings it closer to my
adult mind which means uh there or other
people's adult minds so there's even
more you know uh connection there i
think or whatever but um
the action's great the comedy's great
the relationships are great the bad guys
helen mirren and lucy liu are fantastic
like
i'm i'm very proud of it i hope i want
it to come out sooner than june of 2023.
that's the thing that makes me crazy
because i was looking at the release
date i'm like oh it comes out next
summer and i'm like are you effing
kidding me it's 20 23. two summers yeah
yeah i'm not down with this well listen
i mean look uh
fortunately we're
we are amongst a a huge
group of very cool characters and
actors that play those characters that
they're already
more established in a lot of ways
because of the dc movies that
pre-existed before we came in so we're
you know we're kind of like the we're a
little bit of a jv coming into the to
the varsity squad and uh you know
there's a lot of titles that need to be
that need to come out to the world and
so if that's where we fall in the queue
because i get it studios have to be you
know you have to make a concerted effort
about
uh not cannibalizing your own time you
know uh titles like you you can't
release them too close to each other
otherwise you might cannibalize each
other plus you have to take into
consideration all the other studios
releases and all that stuff so that's
where it is but but you never know maybe
it'll come out sooner
here's here's here's hoping and praying
i hope listen summer summer 2023 means
they're very confident in the movie it's
just that's the time that they figured
out so i of course have to ask you um
have you been in in any contact with
dwayne and like bad mouthing each other
about who's actually gonna win when you
two fight no no no no i mean there's
been there's been some funny little
things back and forth like in character
on twitter or something like that so
somebody had asked him like you know
what what is how how could shazam
possibly stand up to black adam and to
which he replied he doesn't but you know
but then he he labels it black out if
black adam is saying that so i don't
know i don't know dwayne i i have no
communication with them but you know i
i know that we're all going to be a part
of you know we're all a part of the big
same big happy dc family and i look
forward to whatever cocktail parties
we're all at together
yeah i i can't wait to see the two of
you in the film together as your
characters i gotta stop there and i'm
just gonna say seriously congrats on
american underdog i thought you did such
a great job and wish you nothing but the
best thanks brother good to see you
you